my guest of course is an emmy
award-winning actress who played phoebe
on friends she also created and starred
in the critically acclaimed series the
comeback and web therapy
her latest series house broken premieres
may 31st on fox
please welcome lisa kudrow i thank you
for being here in person
that fun isn't it nice safe we're good
we're very safe we've both been
uh vaccinated 15 times yes i don't think
that's too much
no i think i think 15 is just right
you know i have to say i've known you
for a very long time and when this whole
uh you know the pandemic broke out and
we all went into quarantine
and i would talk to you on zoom there
was part of me that would think
you know knowing lisa the way i do i
think
she's suited to quarantine i think
you've always wanted to be quarantined
a reason to yeah yeah you wanted a
reason
but that's kind of your natural state is
can i stay at home right
i love being home it's the best because
i remember
uh you know back in the day you know
when we were young you know super young
early 20s and i knew you i was always
wanting to like hit the clubs and get
out there and rave and put
and push it to the edge and you're
always like no no
people should stay home you know what i
mean do you remember that
i just made that all up i know i never
went out i never
it's funny and i met you in an improv
class and that was too hard for me to
say yes
and it was
what you're saying is the information i
put out there well andy you knew the
later me the guy that wanted to rave and
club and just push it to the max
oh absolutely yeah yeah boy that guy
that that's how you do it yeah that's
called yes
and andy agreed with the crazy
information i put out
didn't we go to a club ever i don't know
i remember seeing like being with you
it's a dark place there's too many
people around for me
right because no i've always been my
setting i danced
i was a dancer at a club and you came to
check it check me out
i remember that very clearly okay i
think i remember that yeah
and you shouted i remember you shouting
you don't have the body for this
very loudly oh now i do remember
he was the only go-go dancer whose cage
was court-ordered
i was like can someone let me out no no
you need to stay in the cage sorry
in the cage now what if you've implanted
these memories and so
like 10 years from now i write a book
conan was a go-go dancer that's what i
want
yeah i i do keep thinking that if i keep
saying this ridiculous stuff
someone's going to pick it up somewhere
and then it's going to end up in a book
like for a while conan was a go-go
dancer
right but is that what you want
falsehoods about yourself yeah they're
much better than the truth
you like the truth yeah you studied
history
okay you like the truth well except
about myself i want lies that make me
look cool
um so many people are excited about this
friends reunion you just shot it yeah
what can you tell us
everybody wants to know and there's just
been this veil of secrecy about the
whole thing but i thought
i know lisa i've known her for a long
time if i get her here she'll tell me
everything
i'll tell you everything i'm allowed to
say okay
do you really get a did you really get a
memo of what you're allowed to say
here's here's what i can say okay um
key phrase that we're allowed to say
okay according to warner media hbo max
joined by special guests we will all the
cast
um we all shoot it's good i like it i
like it so far
and the fact that you made a little bit
of an error there adds excitement to it
like this is really happy it's real and
there's pressure
yeah okay okay joined by special guests
we all the cast return to the original
soundstage
stage 24 on the warner brothers studio
lot
for an unscripted reunion special in
celebration
of the show so
isn't that exciting that's what you're
allowed to say
you know to tempt people yeah sure
well man so i think that whoever wrote
that knows showmanship
they know it's actually it's it's kind
of dangerous
yeah the way it's phrased it could cause
a stampede
also stage 24 yeah like everyone knows
no you did not go back to stage 24.
for friends come on you know i
we're wrapping things up and we're
obviously not at warner brothers right
now but i
we were there for you know almost we
were there for 10 years a decade at
warner brothers and i constantly saw
uh trams with tourists go through warner
brothers
and people were always wanting to see
the friends fountain
the iconic friends fountain yeah and
you'd hear them go by like where's the
friends fountain
and sometimes they'd come they'd like
drive by me and the tour guide would say
and that's conan o'brien and it'd be
like
where's the friend spout
i was like i'm a person um did you guys
you can tell me this did you reenact the
iconic you know
opening where you guys are all
frolicking in the fountain no
but i said it with excitement right no
but
but uh-huh we're at the fountain and
there's footage that i've never seen
before
that i was really excited about
of course so i mean if you do like the
founder interested
if we did that then yes that would be
kind of
thrilling and you'll see and what i like
is that it sounds like you're going to
look at a lot of footage that people
haven't seen before and you guys will
take us to that moment or look at
footage that we haven't seen before
well and that is like clips from the
show
that some of us still never saw well
that's the other thing is you never
watched
a lot of the shows i shouldn't say that
you never watched all of friends
right right because at first yes we all
got together we watched
every episode but you know like uh the
last few years and i had a child and
look honestly it wasn't like i'm not
interested and who cares
it was more i have to be just honest i'm
so self-conscious of
okay everybody shh i'm on tv now
you know i can't do i have no problem
doing that
well yes gather round i'm on television
kids quiet and we begin
daddy i'm bleeding quiet bleed and we'll
take her to the hospital later
you can do your homework later
you can take the sats another day you're
watching me now
your son i don't want to embarrass your
son but he's grown up into
one of the coolest handsomest guys i've
ever seen in my life it's
comical uh just uh how good looking and
nice and suave he is
uh does does julian know the show does
he watch the show or was that weird for
him like i can't watch a show that my
mom's on
yeah we haven't talked about wise
i just know that he hasn't seen every
episode
i mean no no i know for a while in
school people were watching it and he
kind of felt like he had
to so that he can participate in what
everyone else was
watching um and he did really think
that everybody else was very funny
on the show and then that's a classic
kid just like
everyone else is funny that's classic
that and then that is true
i think for all of us i'm not sure i
can't i don't know but i know that he
you know he would say but and you're
funny too
he's like thanks hey don't be too sad
when uh when he was growing up can i
just i have to say something
true and nice he was able to uh
come to the reunion okay
other a tent you know not in the
audience and all that
really said covet safe and afterward
uh he came up to me and he just said
i don't know this is awkward or
inappropriate
can i say that i'm really proud of you
oh
that's so nice yes that was one of the
very emotional things that happened to
me
that's not part of it but you know just
like
oh it was really nice of him yeah
that's that's a beautiful moment yeah
not because he saw the show and went god
she's good
yeah but i think you know that's okay
too
you i mean he grew up kind of on that
set in the early years you would bring
him to the set
and he got a little confused like he i
know that he really was obsessed with
jen aniston yeah no no he'd fly into her
lap
like as if well she's a love bug
and you know and that made sense and i
was always glad for
anyone that julian felt love for and
felt from
um but then at home like she'd be on tv
and he'd go
mommy
so that's got to be a little scarring
maybe
i guess i remember it yeah for a reason
not scarring but just sort of
is this well you know i'm kind of
analytical so i'm like is this wishful
thinking
or do they have some kind of higher
soul connection that i don't have with
him
well i'm happy for both of them yeah
well i want to make sure i mention
uh house broken in this oh that would be
good yeah yeah
well you know we mention everything here
uh
house broken um your character
it's an animated show and you are a
poodle
in this and does this feel like a good
fit for you this character this poodle
yes i'm shaking my head no
yeah yeah yeah it does it feels like a
good fit because she's
the person who's in charge and a little
controlling
you like that yeah yeah and um
and she's pretty but
no to me what's funny about her though
is that um
you know she's she she's not like
funsy but knows she kind of needs to be
so she throws it
out there and it's right doesn't land
and i love that
when someone's trying to be something
they're just not even a little bit
but also it's like you're so good at
like
and one of the things that i've loved
that you've done in your
career after friends is you've found all
these roles and ways to be someone
completely different
than phoebe and just looking at
like web therapy it feels like you have
a lot of fun when you're playing someone
who's trying to control things or the
comeback you're trying to control things
you're not sure why everyone's laughing
always and
your sense of humor is so great but you
seem to love to play people who
don't quite have that yeah which is like
fun for you i think it's the most fun
for me because i think everyone is
hilarious potentially you know
right um and and to me what's funny is
when people just have no clue about how
they're coming off
when i see it in myself i'm mortified
i mean it like it takes me out for a
couple days because
you know how did i miss that how did i
miss that you know
right but um well you're very hard on
yourself you're very self-critical
yeah just this is becoming this is
becoming a therapy session
you're too hard on yourself is what i'm
saying but uh
but i love that you've you seem to just
delight in playing these
people and it sounds like you're doing
it again playing this character who
sort of wants to control things but
doesn't quite understand
exactly you know what's funny in the
room
no she doesn't she knows she needs to
lighten things up right
at times that's just like one that's
just one facet of this extremely
complicated
animated character but um
was that written for you too on your
phone no
i made that up myself uh-huh uh-huh it
was articulate well i want to mention
this
house broken premieres may 31st
uh on nine i'm sorry at nine on fox
and um i wanted to do something kind of
special which is as
you know we met each other at an improv
class and this is one of those crazy
closing the circle moments
because we're wrapping things up here at
tbs yeah and
i'm getting nostalgic about all kinds of
things that i've been
involved with over the years like one of
the
i don't really precious memories of mine
is deciding when i first came out here
to la
85 that i wanted to do improv
and start trying to perform and so i
scoured around i found that there was a
class
here at this theater yeah and i went
there
and it was one of those classes was
taught by cynthia spaghetti you'd put
money in the jar when you came in
i came into this class and one of the
first people i
saw was you in the class this is how we
met
yep and um i
immediately identified you as someone
really special
and someone really hilarious and
talented who was going to do big things
and we the the room where we met
is right there across the little
courtyard and i thought it might be fun
have you been back to that room no yeah
so i thought it might be fun
here at the end of the segment if we
would just walk over
and check out sort of where we met and
and this is an
inspirational message to everybody who's
in a little improv class
i swear to god this is how you do it you
go there you
and you meet amazing people whether it's
an acting class an improv class or doing
stand-up in a club that's where you meet
people and you're young and you have
dreams
and it can really work out pretty
beautifully so want to go check it out
yes let's go right now it's right here
hide it
yeah okay it's a room filled with
asbestos
oh but don't worry i don't believe that
that's exciting thank you very much
oh my god okay making me look rude
always flanny
there you go i just i went first to test
the stairs